you were talking about how women how
like disgusted you are that women may
have an abortion in the ninth month
right or or even a viable maybe of a
viable baby that could and I I wanted to
scream at that time being like women who
have abortions in the ninth month
they're not doing that because they got
bored or all of a sudden they're like oh
I don't care anymore they do that
because it's a tragedy like
statistically women who are getting
abortions in the ninth month is because
there's a medical complication that
could kill them that's why they have to
do it
I already said the real world already
said viable I'll try again what are you
talking about Tim I would say Sad
abortion a viable fetuses ridiculous you
know you know Bible means yes yes it
means the baby can survive complicated
absolutely and why the liberalized
abortion of viable fetus is at nine
months when the baby could just women
are not getting abortions at the ninth
month for pleasure or because they want
to suddenly do it for kicks no that
doesn't happen it's a tragedy
because because there are medical
operations that could kill the mother
and they need to get an abortion why
legalize I just told you that's the
reason why so all right I'll try and
break it down for you if can the baby
survive okay let's let's talk about a
baby the baby can survive on its own yes
sure okay abortion is defined by Planned
Parenthood and the law as terminating
the life of the of the baby correct why
terminate the life of the baby if it can
survive on its own because it could kill
both of them that's why it is done at
that stage so one or the other and they
have to make the tough decision at that
point so how do you remove the fully
formed 9 month baby at that point oh I
don't know the signs of it I I've never
before that operation so shouldn't the
law then be
if the baby must be removed and it is
alive and capable of survival all
actions must be taken to preserve the
life of the child and the mother uh I
would say they'd probably choose the
mother first right why and and then this
is such a strange scenario how often do
you think that this happens and all of a
sudden they're like the baby could have
lived you could have done it why did you
choose the other option it's like this
is a tragedy of the highest order
because they want to have the kid at
nine months pregnant a woman is on her
way to give birth so it's like it's the
worst possible that's not always again I
said I didn't want a dog pile but that's
the I mean that's it's statistically not
true there have been surveys done on
women who had later abortions and for a
pretty large sum of them it's because
they were not sure whether the father of
the child was willing to commit and then
when they found out he wasn't willing to
commit they would have the abortion uh
and so there are different stats you're
going to find for different points in
pregnancy when it comes all the way
along to nine months I don't have the
statistical uh data on that however I do
know for later term abortions there are
reasons other than what is traditionally
considered to be a medically necessary
reason for example some people will say
that um
a negative mental health outcome is a
reason to abort a child later in
pregnancy so if the woman is depressed
they will list that as a reason for why
the child had to be terminated to save
the life of the mother which is
certainly not the case very obviously
and to the point of what Tim is saying
when we say there's no such thing as a
medically necessary abortion the
principle behind that is if there is an
operation which is necessary to save the
life of the mother and then she
miscarries the child as a result of that
operation which was necessary to save
her life that's not an abortion because
nobody's intent was to go in there and
end the life of The Unborn Child and so
if a woman's having complications where
she has to deliver early you deliver the
child early of course and if you're at a
point in pregnancy where the child isn't
viable that's a horrible tragedy you
still do what you can to save the child
but you can't always save the child and
we understand that but to go in and rip
the Child Apart to end their life is
never something which is medically
required even though an early delivery
maybe but what are there situations
where if the baby is in this is so harsh
uh in its complete form that even trying
to induce early pregnancy could kill the
mother so they have to break the baby's
body apart so that they can get it out
without killing the mother I've never
heard of such a thing so and there are
there are Letters by the way son signed
by literally thousands of doctors
so 88 of abortions are in the first 12
weeks 88 88 of abortions less than 1.3
percent of abortions take place near the
eighth or ninth month how many is that
good marker well how many is that I
don't know the actual numbers 13 000.
okay but we're talking about less than
one point three percent hold on 13 000
that's the number of people who die from
gun violence in the US each year that
aren't suicide
to justify abortion when it happens as
it is 13
000 times I said it's extremely there is
338 million Americans I'm sorry the
numbers are going to be a little
daunting yes the numbers will be high
I'm not here to celebrate that I don't
understand your argument then my
argument is something a thousand people
die from Guns we have a problem right
if 13 000 people die from cancer poem
yes of course 13 000 late term abortions
happen is that a problem these are
completely different things how so okay
so if some dies by got a big shot where
they killed it they killed himself was
it a suicide was it a big violence thing
who knows
yes but in the case of late term
abortions more often than not when
statistics say and they when they are
pulled they say the reason that they are
giving it is because it's a medical
complication that could result in a
death so so let's uh I should can we
make the argument then that um
the use of guns on people are allowed
the use of Guns of people and their
lives is allowed murder you're
describing murder
so if Colorado for instance passes a law
saying there is no medical requirement
for an abortion
is it is it wrong to to kill the baby
you're talking about you're trying to
compare murdering someone with a gun to
a woman having to make a medical
decision that could basically preserve
her life not not a medical reason that's
that's what I'm saying should she have
the ability to have an abortion for any
reason yes at nine months at nine months
I would say at nine months because it
only happens according to the stats
based on uh complete medical necessity
she has a right to do it
Colorado legalized abortion in up to
nine months with no medical reason
required
do you agree I agree with that decision
yeah so so the baby could survive on its
own and the mother is legally now
allowed to just end its life she has the
right if she wanted to you're saying so
in Colorado and I'm not your question I
know I know but but I'm asking but I'm
asking you because you're the one who
brought this up I don't know what
Colorado specific law says so if you
were saying that in Colorado women have
the ability at nine months to get to
have an abortion for any reason they
could just decide yeah okay I think they
should have the right to do that but the
stats show that they're not doing that
but they should have a legal right to do
that yes it's their body it's their
choice of course so this is what I do I
disagree on I think if the baby needs to
be removed from the woman there's no
reason to kill it you know what I mean
like you could just C-section and then
put up for adoption I'm telling you that
doesn't happen but it does but but even
but but like you might be able to bring
up anecdotes but the stats don't I did
say that hold on hold on hold on hold on
like why allow it to happen I just don't
understand are are you arguing what's
going on are you arguing you oppose it
and you think it's morally wrong but you
think it should be legal I I think that
women should have the right to decide
what they do and have bodily autonomy
over their own body we're not talking
about her body we're talking it is her
body we're talking about nine months
even if it's still inside it's still her
body even if it's a violence
removal of the baby yes the forceful
removal of the baby or forceful so she
chooses to have that she's the woman
says the baby must be removed from my
body why kill the baby if they're
removing it I don't think they should do
that I would I would if they ask me if
they ask me lenses should I do this I
would say no but she should have a right
yes of course it's her body still no
that doesn't stop so like the woman is
pregnant the baby is viable and capable
of surviving on its own sure and she
says before it hits before it breaches
oxygen kill it do you think that should
be allowed this is again the baby
Guillotines this is why I brought that
up but but what a weird scenario this
doesn't happen this is not the real
world but it does and if the argument is
that doesn't happen enough for you to
care that's fine you're allowed to
believe that sure what I don't
understand is it seems like you your
position is a rather shock position
where you recognize there is something
in here wrong with taking the life of a
baby that could survive on its own but
you also but you're also taking the
tribal position of women should be
allowed to do it anyway no no if you
were to ask me Tim hey Lance do you
think it's a good idea of this woman
who's nine months pregnant suddenly she
got bored with the pregnancy she doesn't
have it anymore but the baby's viable do
you think that's a good thing to do I
would be like no of course I should be
allowed because it's still her right
it's still her body but bodily autonomy
doesn't stop at my morality Tim it's not
my choice it's not my yes but that's not
my choice
that's her choice not mine why kill the
baby ask her so ask her okay so my point
is simply this you don't need to be
shocked by it you're allowed to have
that moral position I think most people
in America would prescribe that to be uh
would ascribe evil to that that's the
idea are you guys describe evils
whatever you want that's up to you
that's your choice the idea that you
would say doesn't mean that she's the
woman who wants the baby removed and
then in the process instead of letting
the baby live remove it but kill it
right there's no reason to do that
there's no you can give the baby up for
adoption you can drop the baby off on
the doorsup of a post office I agree
with you I legalize even if it's one one
why legalize you see this is the
craziest thing her autonomy should not
be cut off based on your morality
because you don't think that idea is
good you don't like it the babies
well that's that's if it was removed
from her body and it was still viable
right and that's where the baby
Guillotines come in because I don't
think this happens I don't think women
on the ninth month get abortions with
viable living children and then be like
I don't want to kill it I don't think
that happens you I mean you don't have
to think it happens but statistically it
does because your entire argument is
this only happens for reasons of the
health of the mother or the health I
said so you guys they showed that at the
ninth month if a woman is going to have
an abortion it's typically because it's
a medical complication that could either
endanger her or the child's life and
what I'm saying is there are doctors who
will justify that by saying the medical
complication is she is depressed that is
literally one of those
okay okay but Sheamus I got to stop you
because this is a nebulous argument that
doesn't get anywhere and and I can
respect the point that uh if if you go
to a left if you try and look this up
you're gonna find left-wing uh sources
and right-wing sources that will
contradict each other so my question is
strictly on the legality of terminating
the life of a child we we I can sit here
and pull up oh hey here's one women uh
abort Down syndrome babies late term
rather frequently I think that's wrong I
don't think that someone's life is
forfeit because they have Down syndrome
but your argument is that they do no
it's not that that's a strong no no no
your argument is that women have a right
to terminate a baby for any reason at
any point yes they should have the
bodily autonomy to make that decision so
what I'm saying is in the circumstance
of down syndrome I think it is wrong to
terminate a baby's life at nine months
simply for having Down syndrome but you
would agree she is legally allowed to do
so I I think she should be legally
allowed to do so whether or not I think
that's a good idea is irrelevant there's
the clarification I think it should be
illegal okay I don't I think so there
are limits to how much bodily autonomy
women should have so yes right uh so
okay so that's your sense the pro-choice
argument because you're pro-abortion
right pro-choice traditionally in this
country put limits at around like 15 to
16 weeks meaning if the baby is
dependent upon the body of the mother
then it is the body of the mother and
she has final say if the baby is viable
it can be removed in in a process that
ends the pregnancy but doesn't end the
life of the baby that's kind of like the
compromise where the baby gets to live
and the woman no longer has to be
pregnant there seems to be this amoral
argument where but it just killed the
baby anyway which doesn't make any
logical sense that's the pro-abortion
side so if you go back to the 90s if you
go back to Safe legal rare Etc if you
even look at Tulsi gabbard in 2020
that's where I'm at conservatives are
pro-life outright Sheamus would argue
abortion in any capacity should be
banned entirely
I'm in the traditional Democrat position
but you see there is a tribal amoral a
logical position of just let them kill
the baby regardless I don't I don't see
any logic there I don't see how that
makes sense morally or ethically or or
just mathematically right so you said
I'm pro-abortion what I'm against is
forced birth and I don't think the state
should be forcing women to give birth
against their will which is what your
position and your position is so so I'm
against that
government I I don't think they
should be forcing them and turning
completely agree viable wounds I
completely agree I'm against forced
birth just like you except my difference
is that if the baby's at eight months
and can survive they can take the baby
out as if they would have an abortion
but not kill it in the process if it's
available at eight months is it viable
yes it is yes it is dude there have been
babies after 20 weeks position is that
women have a right to kill the baby even
if they end the pregnancy and there's no
logic there the logic is that I don't
think you you agree with forced birth at
a point how at eight months at eight
months Tim pool thinks Force birth is
cool
a woman could end her pregnancy whenever
she wants say it Tim Poole said a woman
can end her pregnancy whenever she wants
yeah
make up something fake Tim Paul agrees
with Force birth is a false statement
you're lying I have already said I
believe that women have a right to
terminate their pregnancy after a
certain amount of time
yes the baby is viable that she
shouldn't have the right to be able to
terminate it to kill the baby yes I said
she can end the pregnancy whenever she
wants and ending the pregnancy can be
giving birth or a boarding or a
C-section that keeps the business she
has to be forced to give birth against
her will in a C-section but the baby is
viable and they give us so how do they
remove it either way the baby comes out
of her so you literally want forced
birth you literally want to force women
to give birth again
they should use the the tools to rip
apart the body and pull that out whereas
I'm saying they should just take it she
should have the right to decide what
happens to her body that's it okay but I
so if all right either way the child is
coming out you're making this argument
about forced birth either way what is in
her body is going to be outside of it
the question is is it okay to shove
forceps into the skull of the small
person who's inside of her and then tear
them apart limb by limb to get them out
or should we say no that's not an
acceptable way of delivering a baby you
shouldn't kill that unborn child how is
that for either way it comes out of her
body either way the child comes out of
her body it's not as if there's one
scenario
magically disappears
forced to birth as a nonsense but yeah
but in your scenario she's being forced
to give birth against her will actually
she's already pregnant dude I know but
we're not talking about anything but
then endorse that position I did stick
by it I know I rejected there's no such
thing I can't kill that here let me let
me tell you how fascinating this is
because she's the last baby so
legalizing the killing of a baby at nine
months that I can sit here and say I
think women should be able to terminate
their pregnancy whenever they want but
if the baby is viable the Judgment no
reason she has she has to be forced to
give it then she has to be forced to
give birth and then give the baby up is
what you're saying give birth Define yes
okay so so that is forced birth right so
so she can't decide to terminate in
eight or nine months Define give birth
you just said at eight months if the
baby is viable I'd say eight months
Define give birth I'm trying to
understand what you're saying by force
to birth what is what does birth mean
you just said when she is at eight or
nine months okay so she's at eight or
nine is that viable okay so it's viable
the baby's viable she should have to
give birth to it in some capacity
C-section whatever Define birth and I
can answer your question birth
the the the
removal of a child into the world from a
mother's womb if the baby so how do they
do that uh the woman pushes the baby out
so then what would you call an abortion
at eight months
is the woman pushing the baby out no
it's most likely a medical procedure
done by a doctor and what is that
medical procedure an abortion like but
what is that what is an abortion yes
like what how is it done I'm not
entirely sure it's done in eight months
I know I know earlier I know earlier on
it's usually done with a series of rules
yeah I don't know how it's done today
okay so your moral argument is forced
birth I'm trying to understand what your
position is
if you don't know how an abortion is
done then are you in favor of forced
birth am I in favor of voice no I'm
against Force birth but you think that
women should have to expel the baby
right it's completely fine for me not to
know the medical procedure of how
abortion is done to stand up for the
rights of a woman's body I don't need to
know how people perform abortions I'm
not gonna lie here I'm not going to
pretend removing a baby from a woman's
body is birth
oh so you're saying it doesn't count
of a different nature I don't think you
have a definition and I'm trying to
understand what you mean by forced birth
but if you can't define the removal of
the baby in a different way I don't know
what you're saying birth birth Tim like
the birth of a child so it's a C-section
of birth uh sure yes it is a form of
extracting the living child uh that is
viable to live in the real world that's
how you define birth extracting a living
child to live in the real world no I
would Divine birth as someone giving
birth they're pushing the baby out of
their body so so right so I don't think
women should be forced to do that right
you don't think women should be forced
to push babies out of the body but the
baby is in their body so it's got to
come out somehow so you're gonna take it
out with a C-section no I don't know but
I'm trying to figure out what you mean
by this so that would be forced birth so
he's forced to give and make a child a
viable Child live in the real world
is coming out of the woman right yes so
there's there's no there's no being in
favor of that or not it happens period
yes okay so what's your point
what's my point am I in favor of a
natural process by which a woman has to
have a baby removed from her no matter
what anyone says or does
your point is that at eight or nine
months and correct me if I'm wrong on
this Tim you are wrong yes I'll stop you
right there because because when you
keep saying eight or nine months that's
not what I said over and over and over
again my ability is after six months
you're also wrong
baby it's not six months so as soon as
the movie is viable Tim as soon as the
baby is viable then it's okay for the
woman even if she doesn't want to have
it anymore for whatever reason she
should have to be forced to have it
extracted from her and and then live is
that correct is that your position well
it's not forcing the woman to have a
baby live if the baby's already alive
you see what I'm saying like right okay
I got semantics I gotta compromise for
it I got a compromise for you we'll tell
the mother we killed it but we'll sneak
it off and give it to someone else does
that work for you no because I still
think she should have autonomy she
should have the right to do it if she
wants to of course she should kill the
baby after I don't want her to kill
because I want her to have the ability
to choose that's different and that is a
fundamental part of this the baby's out
of her body right forcibly of course
let's of course let's say 24 weeks let
me go to the doctor and says I want this
baby out of me what did she says I don't
want to have this baby I don't I don't
want to have this baby okay okay and the
doctor says I will remove it okay oh the
baby's alive what do we do so you force
her to give birth no no no she said
Doctor I'd like an abortion he says you
got it he's lying to her no no he does
the abortion and it fails an abortion is
terminating in pregnancy so there's no
there's no such thing as a trick
abortion they're called failed abortions
failed abortions doctors like trick
women into taking demands no no no no no
no so when they perform the abortion as
Sheamus explained they stick metal tools
into the brain and scramble it up and
rip its body parts apart okay and then
pull it out chunk by chunk okay when the
babies are smaller sometimes they pull
them out but the babies don't die they
survive right so my question is in the
instance of a failed abortion what
should be done
a failed abortion being that the the
child is living it's outside of the
mother yeah at that point you cannot
kill that child that would be murder oh
okay agreed on that point right yeah so
then where does the mother's Choice come
in for before that procedure takes place
so she she has a choice to choose what
she wants to have done with her body if
if she goes to a doctor and the doctor's
like I'm gonna perform an abortion which
the assumption would be that I'm about
to terminate the child but then he just
secretly sneaks the child out of there
that's not performing an abortion you're
just
being deceptive yeah and the doctor
would should go to prison if they did
something like that in my opinion I'd
like to go to prison if you should go to
prison if he performs an abortion snap
yeah I heard that opposite perspective
so there's also something that none of
us know because I don't think any of us
are medical doctors the the difference
on the physiology of the female body uh
giving a nine-month abortion having that
happen or the actual birthing process
whether by C-section or natural birth uh
it might have vastly different
consequences on the female body so
that's something to take into oh so so
wait wait remember the born alive act
yes that was a republican position
wasn't it what was it what was that yeah
so there have been a couple of different
born alive acts in different years but
what they basically say is that if the
abortion fails it is not legal to kill
the child
wasn't wasn't that Republicans were
trying to pass Republicans were trying
to pass that that was one of the only
things Obama voted on in the Senate he
voted against it
Obama voted against it against but you
would be in favor of that
infant for what the born alive act I'm
not completely familiar with it so if an
infant is born alive after an attempted
abortion it has the same protection of
Law and degree as a newborn
um yeah I would be okay with that
because at that point it's it's uh it's
a human if you're killing the person
that is alive outside of a womb then
that's murder right yeah I agree can I
ask you this is not a God that's great I
want to ask in good faith so yeah of
course you believe that the moment after
the child is outside of the birth canal
that they are now endowed with human
rights yes however when they are inside
of the mother literally anything you do
to them is acceptable because they're
inside of the mother oh no I don't think
anything is acceptable but I think the
mother should still have the choice
ultimate uh authority over what happens
to her body but there's a child inside
uh like should she be allowed to do meth
yeah
uh I think if someone is doing meth
while they're pregnant that it is
completely acceptable for something like
uh
I don't know the name of the services in
the United States Child Services would
be yeah it's our body though
yeah it's her body she wants to do math
what's the big deal
uh the big deal is that it's she's
intentionally trying to kill a child
hold on there a minute yeah and I see
where we're going I don't I don't
understand what you're saying it's her
body it's her body wants to do meth
what's the problem
well first off doing meth is a legal
period doesn't matter if you're doing it
with a child without a child
methyl and dioxide MDMA maybe it's
alcohol wait sorry not Crystal Method
Crystal methods no not crystals hold on
a second MDMA is a kind of methodoxy
methamphetamine is uh ecstasy that's a
kind of meth there's also crystal meth
which is not legal MDMA is legal in some
places for therapy sessions I don't know
if it's legal yes pregnant women okay it
is possession
okay dude so like sorry decentralizing
possession is different than legalizing
Crystal mouths you know you know those
two things are completely different
right uh
yeah so hold on yeah what so you so when
you decriminalize a small amount of
drugs that means if you're caught with
that drugs by a cop that means if you're
arrested you cannot be charged for one
gram two grams whatever that is
legalizing is no this is
decriminalization not legalization
legalization is a semantic term it
doesn't mean anything yes it means it
means that there's no longer a
Prohibition on that product okay so if a
woman does meth she's legally allowed to
have it right is she legally allowed to
do it or possess it
I mean what's the difference well two
very different things you can be legally
allowed to possess drugs and not be
legally allowed to take drugs for
example alcohol
so she does alcohol can a woman chug a
fifth of vodka while pregnant uh yeah
she can legally but do you think she has
a right to do so
I think she has a right to do yes she
has a right to do it I don't agree with
it okay yeah and and and heroin
uh it's illegal I actually I don't think
heroin I think heroin actually is was
legalized I think it's controlled but I
think that one specifically was
oxycodone and Other Drugs so
she has a right to do it whether or not
I agree with her doing it that's
completely different I don't agree with
a woman who would have an elective
abortion at nine months I think that
that is like why the about that but
I think she has the right to do it right
but do you think it's ethical that she
like oh I don't think it's ethical no of
course not because some some things are
made legal that are unethical in my
opinion and should those be made illegal
uh I mean that's a very broad question
right no no I'm sorry personal use of
methamphetamine is allowed it's a it's a
civil citation like a traffic ticket not
a criminal citation so allowed maybe is
hyperbolic uh it is a simple citation to
be caught using uh methamphetamine in
Oregon you get a ticket for it but not
no no crime so I just looked up the born
alive act by the way it says this bill
is deliberately misleading and offensive
to pregnant people and doctors and
nurses who provide their care it is
another attempt by anti-abortion
politicians to spread misinformation as
a means to get a war political end to
ban safe and legal abortion it's an
entry point to try and make abortion
illegal where did you read this okay
I don't care I mean who cares about the
born alive act the question was if an
abortion happens but the baby survives
can you kill it and he Lance already
said no so I I we're done with it so he
would yeah yeah yeah for sure so at any
other political arguments anyone left
right or otherwise trying to change that
no no it's irrelevant once the baby's
born it's it's a baby so yeah so it has
the same rights as every other human at
that point right this is an American
this is an interesting I I think this
this Falls in line with the idea of
anarcho tyranny that we were talking
about the my view of the modern left is
that their positions are nothing but
chaos there there's there's no logical
pathway towards preserving life uh
improving people's lives it seems to be
only it's like it's like it's like yin
yang right there's one side that's
talking about long-term planning logical
thinking and improving the world on one
side that takes the inverse position no
matter what for instance 25 people push
in front of a subway nobody bats an eye
one guy three guys try to subdue a man
and now they want prison that's like a
weird inversion of what the law is
supposed to do the law should stop the
people who are pushing people on the
trains and protect the people on the
train who are being victimized but the
left's position is the inverse of it
right
are all chaos I mean if you really
wanted to boil down what the left is
fighting for especially myself it's
expanding freedom I I believe in Freedom
I love freedom I'm sure everyone here
likes Freedom too right here how do you
define Freedom exactly so for me I I
believe in a democratic process where we
don't have tyrants we don't have
dictators we don't have Kings or Queens
we have the ability as a democracy to be
able to vote for who we work for or
sorry who who our leaders are right like
we want to be able to vote for our
president our prime minister I I believe
in that fundamentally but my other thing
is I want to expand that freedom into
the workplace because we spend about
eight hours a day every single day in
our works our jobs I want to expand
Freedom there so people who work at
their jobs for eight hours a day have
the ability to vote for things in their
lives Better Health Care better working
conditions whether or not their boss is
corrupt and stealing from all of them I
want to expand that I want to expand
Freedom into other parts of life that's
that's a fundamental belief what do you
mean by stealing from them uh stealing
wages for example like actually shorting
someone's check and so so the largest
form of theft in America right now is
wage theft if you had to happen to me I
sued I I went to the National Labor
Board and we won how does it happen as
you should so there's a ton of words
paying over time not paying overtime uh
bosses uh simply just garnishing checks
or garnishing wages stealing tips or
thinking that tips for justification to
pay them lower salaries and stuff like
that yeah all of it and when
you look at theft every single like you
look at the stats right cars being
stolen jewelry all that wage theft blows
everything out like they're not even
comparable it's one down here and then
it's like the other one's all
the way up there I got a story for you
so uh I worked at a company I get a
paycheck I'm good at math and stuff and
so I look at it and I'm like hey there's
a problem with my paycheck and they go
no it's good I'm like no it isn't
there's a problem with my paycheck fix
it and I I very quickly it was like 67
missing I want it fixed and I want to
fix now and they went uh give us a few
minutes came back 15 minutes later
handed me a check I looked at it and
said are you joking
and they were like huh and I was like
this is wrong I'm not an idiot fix my
paycheck
went to a couple other employees they
said I said let me see your paychecks I
looked and I went come with me walked
right to the National Labor Board in
Chicago and said this is what they did
they took our statements we went to the
company and we told them we were going
to form a union because of what they had
done they fired us on the spot for doing
it we sued them and then uh I'll give
you air quotes and saying we won what
actually happened was after six months
of being out of work they said you can
get retropay which will be seven
thousand dollars each or we can go to
fight and then I'll give you your job
back and I'm like if they give us our
job back they're going to retaliate
against us no no that's illegal and I
was like oh come on so we won the fight
but it really means they were able to
fire us to stop us from forming a union
so what would be a good example of
expanding sorry oh no no I just want to
make the point uh I'm not I haven't seen
the stats on wage theft causing more in
losses than all other forms of theft
combined I'll just have to take your
word for that and I'm willing to grant
that for the sake of it I think that
this is yeah yeah like I said I'm I'm
willing to Grant it if that is the case
and at the very least for the sake of
argument I certainly don't agree and
involuntarily democratizing all
workplaces that's probably a much longer
interesting economic discussion happy to
engage in it with you guys too and I
suspect we would all have different
views on it I don't know if you wanted
other issues I would like to talk about
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time